trois défis
communisme communisante
vérité
d'hommes semblables les niveaux
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous écoutez
scopeo l'observatoire politique je suis
luca membre de scopeo et je vous
souhaite la bienvenue sur notre chaise
roulante revue les politiques numéro 14
aujourd'hui nous sommes très heureux de
poursuivre notre série d'entrevues
politique avec madame emmanuelle ducrocq
journaliste économique chez les médias
l'opinion au programme d'aujourd'hui
nous allons aborder questionner notre
modèle d'agriculture classe maintenant
la parole à deux missives membres de
scopeo pour qu'elle pose plus
précisément le décor est ce podcast
merci au gabon jouera celle de ceux qui
nous écoutent et surtout bonjour à vous
madame emmanuelle du pro bonjour bonjour
à tous vous nous fait le plaisir
aujourd'hui de nous accorder cette
entrevue pour discuter ensemble de votre
vision de l'agriculture pour la france
vous traitez vous même fréquemment de ce
thème sur les médias dans vos articles
et dans vos interventions publiques
notamment que les sujets relatifs à
l'agriculture biologique à la condition
de vie de nos agriculteurs français à
notre alimentation aux pesticides à la
cause animale mais avant de démarrer
l'entrevue madame micro je vous laisse
vous présenter brièvement pour ceux qui
nous écoutent et bien vous l'avez déjà
fait beaucoup je suis bonjour à tous je
suis donc journalistes pour l'opinion un
média qui a fêté ses mi-temps l'année
dernière qui fêtera ses 9 ans cette
année qui est un média récent qu'on
trouve en kiosque et qu'on trouve en
ligne et je m'occupe pour ce média
effectivement des questions
d'alimentation de l'agriculture aussi
des questions de transport et un petit
peu des questions de teck
je collabore avec d'autres médias pour
le compte de l'opinion notamment avec
lci et avant de travailler pour
l'opinion j'ai été longtemps journaliste
financier dans un quotidien spécialisé
et dans la bourse voilà à peu près ce
que je pouvais vous dire
tout d'abord partant dans le constat
évident est partagé par tous la grille
aux jo française qui était un fleuron
national est en perte de vitesse et si
rien n'est fait la france sera
importatrice nette en 2023 c'est à dire
que nous aurons plus souvent au niveau
de notre alimentation face à ce constat
terrible comment expliquez vous que ce
sujet soit délaissée par la classe
politique et que la question de la
souveraineté alimentaire ne semble
intéressé ni les médias ni les
responsables économiques des publics
bien disons que je pense qu on a été
habitué à être très gâtés dans ce
domaine l'un depuis la fin des années 60
la france a conquis son indépendance de
sa souveraineté alimentaire alors je
vais pas revenir là-dessus après joueurs
définition de ce concept de souveraineté
alimentaire parce qu'il ya des choses
qu'on peut évidemment pas produire sur
notre sol mais ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que dans l'après guerre
on s'est rendu compte que la france
était extrêmement dépendante de
l'extérieur pour se nourrir notamment
parce qu'à cette époque là elle avait
encore des colonies qui l'alimenté en
fruits en légumes en céréales en raisins
en matières grasses aussi et on a fait
le constat que la france avait une
structure agricole qui était obsolète et
qui ne permettait pas de se nourrir et
d'ailleurs les agriculteurs avaient
souvent une un mode de production qui
était relativement vivriers et
produisait pas beaucoup plus que ce que
consomme et leurs familles et donc on a
lancé dans les années 60 c'était le
ministre la culture edgar pisani grande
réforme de l'agriculture on l'a
considérablement modernisé on a on a par
exemple moderniser la sélection des
semences pour avoir des semences qui
sont un peu plus productives on a aussi
revendre et ce qui est aujourd'hui très
discutée et les pertes agricoles etc et
on est passé dans une agriculture plus
modèles certains des héros industriel
c'est pas ma vision des choses mais une
entité à une agriculture qui faisait
appel à des fertilisants à des produits
protection des plantes ce qu'on appelle
couramment des pesticides mais qui est
assez est un peu réducteur comme
vocabulaire et la france a conquis son
indépendance alimentaire de cette
manière là et elle est devenue une sorte
de pays de cocagne le plus grand
producteur de l'union européenne un pays
qui se singularise par la variété de ses
productions par la qualité de ses
productions siens parce que on critique
beaucoup notre agriculture mais quand on
la regarde de l'extérieur elle est
réputée pour sa et
petit à petit cette espèce de constat de
pays de cocagne c'est
comment dire s'est érodée parce que de
législation sur transposer de l'europe
en coût du travail excessifs en règle
toujours plus compliqué pour pour
implanter des des exploitations
agricoles en mauvaise rémunération en
fuite des nouvelles générations et bien
on arrive à ce constat qu'aujourd'hui
effectivement si on enlève les vins et
spiritueux de notre balance commerciale
la france importe de la nourriture et ce
qui est encore plus grave
c'est que oui effectivement elle est
dépendant par exemple en termes de
fruits et légumes on en importe entre 40
et 60% alors il reste des postes qui
sont exportateurs en france et qui sont
solides et c'est important les postes
céréaliers le poste des boissons par
exemple un petit peu le poste des
laitages mais pour le reste on a
effectivement perdu cette chose
essentielle qui est la capacité de choix
de choix de la manière dont on produit
notre nourriture puisque on importe des
choses qu'on ne peut plus ou qu'on ne
veut plus faire chez nous
merci beaucoup la question de la
démographie doit aussi être abordées les
agriculteurs exploitants représente
aujourd'hui seulement 1,5 pour cent de
l'emploi total en france concède un pour
cent en 1982 au niveau de la pyramide
des âges aussi les suspects sont
alarmants seul 1% des agriculteurs ont
moins de 25 ans tandis que 55% des
agriculteurs français ont plus de 50 ans
et 13% plus de 60 passant d'une france
rurale et l inévitable selon vous et
comment pouvez vous expliquer ce
désamour pour les métiers agricoles
alors effectivement vous avez raison de
le souligner il va falloir renouveler
d'ici à
2030 35 la moitié des agriculteurs de
france donc c'est un défi absolument
terrible alors la fin des agriculteurs
ne veut pas dire la fin de la ruralité
sont deux choses différentes mais
effectivement ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que une ferme qui
ferment quelque part en france ça veut
dire une activité économique qui s'est
incliné remplacé à rien d'autre c'est à
dire que si par exemple un commerce
ferme en ville est remplacé par autre
chose si une usine ferme une chance
qu'elle soit reprise ou les bâtiments
servent à autre chose rack une autre
activité s'implante quand il ferme ferme
ça n'est pas une ferme il n'y a pas
forcément autre chose qui ce qui somme
qui s'installe au même endroit et donc
effectivement c'est une dévitalisation
économie qui va bien au delà de
l'agriculture alors le désamour il vient
de plusieurs choses disons que les
agriculteurs ayant produit plus il s'est
révélé moins important d'en avoir
beaucoup pour asseoir notre production
alimentaire ça a marché un certain temps
mais on se rend compte aujourd'hui que
les attentes des consommateurs qui vont
par exemple vers des produits bio
implique des baisses de rendement de la
moitié à peu près donc ça veut dire
qu'il va bien faire trouver quelqu'un
pour produire cette nourriture alors
vous avez raison il y a un enjeu
d'installation des jeunes générations
c'est vraiment quelque chose de capital
c'est vraiment quelque chose d'important
et c'est aussi une vraie chance pour
l'agriculture parce que les jeunes qui
viennent à l'agriculture sont pour une
partie
à peu près la moitié des gens qui sont
issus d'un cadre familial à l'école mais
pour une autre moitié des gens qui
viennent d'un autre monde soit des
jeunes qui vont s'installer en
agriculture comme début de carrière soit
des gens qui font des reconversions
professionnelles qui viennent à
l'agriculture avec un autre comme
mondiale un autre héritage culturel une
autre manière d'envisager les choses et
peut-être aussi moins de poids sur leurs
épaules le poids de la tradition parce
que la tradition ça a du bon la
tradition c'est aussi parfois quelque
chose on doit s'affranchir pour innover
pour progresser et parfois les
agriculteurs disent que la tradition ça
leur pèse alors il ya plusieurs
chantiers qui va falloir envisager il
faut aider effectivement les jeunes à
s'installer parce que s'installer dans
une ferme ça coûte très cher beaucoup
d'investissements il faut des machines
il faut du matériel il ya un point qui
est absolument considérable c'est celui
de la terre le foncier ça coûte
extrêmement cher et les jeunes
agriculteurs souvent se lance dans la
vie active avec un énorme poids de dec
parce qu'ils ont dû
acheter la terre donc peut-être qu'il va
falloir pour comment dire rendre les
installations plus facile repenser la
façon dont on gère la terre peut-être
que des structures publiques peuvent se
charger de la détenir et la m et la
mettre à disposition avec des bail de
très longue durée à des jeunes
exploitants de façon à ce qu'ils
puissent se projeter sur la durée sur
des terres alors qu'il ne leur
appartient au groupe a en propre mais
qui vont être chargés de valoriser de
soigner d'exploiter et c'est donc il ya
beaucoup de pistes à reprendre les
modèles d'agriculture aussi sont à
repenser en pour ce qui est de leurs
équilibres économiques ya aujourd'hui
des activités agricoles qui arrive
péniblement à l'équilibré
quand elles ne sont pas déficitaires et
effectivement c'est difficile de
valoriser un métier quand on sait qu'on
gagnera pas sa vie très très bien voir
qu'on tirera le diable par la queue une
année sur deux alors il faut absolument
pulvérisée celui de l'agriculteur qui
gagnerait 380 euros par mois ce chiffre
là il est largement contestée il a fait
beaucoup de mal à la profession agricole
parce qu'il a comment dire dévaloriser
la perspective de carrière et l'intérêt
du métier cela dit effectivement il faut
qu'on arrive à repenser des modèles
agricoles qui soit efficace
économiquement qu'ils soient plus
rémunérateurs et puis parce que c'est
aussi une fierté de vivre de son travail
et d'être regardée par la société dans
son ensemble comme quelqu'un qui nourrit
les autres
avec fierté qui gagne sa vie de cette
façon
alors vous écoutant l'impression qu'il
ya énormément de deux problèmes à
traiter mais aussi de solutions à
apporter et pourtant on a l'impression
que c'est pas bon mais les premières
préoccupations des français dans les
sondages et du coup quand on parle pas
beaucoup dans la campagne présidentielle
qui se lance on a l'impression que les
sujets majoritaire de touche absolument
bas la réalité même pour les candidats
qui revendiquent une attache ou
territoires défavorisés comment est-ce
que vous l'expliquer alors je m'explique
difficilement la ruralité c'est encore
en 80 % notre territoire et à environ
30% des habitants donc c'est en lui que
ça concerne quand même un tiers un tiers
de nos compatriotes la ruralité au sens
large du terme c'est à dire les gens qui
vivent pas dans l'est dans les villes on
est loin des centres urbains
jeu jeunesse ne m'explique pas comment
un sujet aussi important que celui un la
souveraineté alimentaire c'est à dire
comment un pays est maître de son destin
de ce qu'il met dans ses assiettes ne
préoccupe pas plus nos politiques c'est
une des première des libertés
c'est aussi un des premiers facteurs de
paix sociale la nourriture le fait qu'un
peuple soit correctement nourris le fait
qu'un peuple ne soit pas nourri par un
système qui seraient à deux vitesses
c'est absolument capital pour la
cohérence pour la cohésion d'un pays et
effectivement ça me ça m'interroge que
nos politiques est globalement des
visions totalement
éthérée de l'agriculture la plupart
d'entre eux se contentent de dire on n'a
qu'à faire du bio et tous les problèmes
seront résolus comme si c'était une
formule magique et sans jamais se rendre
compte des implications que ça en termes
de production en termes économiques etc
pour moi c'est vraiment un mystère ça
devrait être un sujet absolument capital
on sait que la population mondiale
atteindra en 2050 10 milliards
d'habitants
qu'il va falloir nourrir cette planète
alors la france contribue un petit peu
un elle peut pas évidemment porter ça
sur ses épaules mais ça veut dire aussi
que des nombreux pays vont se retrouver
en concurrence pour l'accès aux
ressources alimentaires et que si la
france n'y fait pas attention elle se
retrouvera non pas en capacité de
maîtriser sa subsistance mais en elle
devra se battre elle aussi sur les six
internationaux pour avoir accès à la
nourriture et ça ça devrait être une
perspective qui fait frémir d'horreur
nos politiques d'autant que généralement
quand des pays sont déstabilisés par la
fin ça crée des vagues migratoires et ça
déstabilise des pays entiers cette
question là elle est de mon point de vue
centrale la conquête de la paix elle
s'est faite par la conquête de la
nourriture par la conquête de la
stabilité alimentaire et pour la
conquête aussi de la variété enfin une
est une société de disette c'est une
société qui généralement va très mal
donc je ne m'explique pas que ce sujet
ne soit pas pris à coeur à bras le corps
par nos politiques d'autant que dans
tout le débat capital qu'on doit avoir
de savoir comment on s'adapte au
réchauffement au réchauffement
climatique
comment on lutte aussi contre le
réchauffement climatique
il y a dans la ruralité et dans le monde
agricole des solutions qui sont
extrêmement importantes l'agriculture ce
n'est pas juste des externalités
négatives c'est à dire des usages de
pesticides
etc c'est aussi une façon de capturer du
carbone dans le sol l'agriculteur est
probablement une des seules activités
humaines qui si elle est repensée si
elle fait une bonne transition peut être
quasiment neutre en termes de carbone
et ce sujet là que les politiques n'ai
pas envie de creuser un petit peu plus
techniquement de se poser un petit peu
plus de questions des cycles globaux qui
leur met par exemple en cause l'élevage
sans se rendre compte que l'élevage
c'est aussi un engrais n'atteint un
engrais jaillir naturel type de n'aime
pas ce mot avec des guillemets qui
permet de se passer d'engrais azotés
dans beaucoup de cas qu'ils ne se
rendent pas compte qu'il ya aussi des
questions énergétiques attaché à
l'agriculture que le biogaz c'est pas
une réponse absolue mais c'est quand
même une partie de la solution
ça me parait ça me paraît assez fou à
vrai dire ça me paraît assez fou et je
suis souvent très étonné du niveau très
bas connaissance de nos politiques sur
les questions alimentaires sur le
simplisme des réponses qu'ils apportent
je vais vous donner un exemple quand on
parle par exemple du glyphosate bon le
glyphosate c'est un herbicide le
glyphosate c'est quelque chose
peut pour la plupart de notre classe
politique il faut éradiquer se sont pas
vraiment posé la question de savoir
pourquoi la thématique est à la mode
voilà le glyphosate et n'est pas un
sujet sanitaire c'est un sujet
idéologique mais ils ne se sont pas
rendu compte que quand on se prive de
glyphosate on se prive de techniques
culturales extrêmement intéressantes
comme l'agriculture de conservation des
sols c'est à dire une agriculture qui
fait beaucoup moins appel aux labours
donc qui utilisent moins de machines qui
émet moins de co2 et qui en même temps
permet de capter dans le sol des de très
très gros volumes de co2 tout en
préservant de l'érosion est un autre
danger pour l'agriculture et qui permet
aussi de développer l'état de cultures
alternatives qui sont très intéressante
par exemple ramène de l'azoté dans le
sol les politiques n'ont aucune espèce
de connaissances sur ce sujet là et
aucune idée des conséquences de leur
choix
la même chose quand on a parlé de la
betterave et les néonicotinoïdes une
partie de la classe politique s'est
précipité pour dire il faut les
interdire tout de suite on ne s'est pas
préoccupé de savoir comment on allait
faire sens comme si c'était magique et
qu'on pouvait faire sans on est en train
de se rendre compte que trois ans après
on n'a pas trouvé de solution unique
c'est très compliqué et le corollaire de
tout ça c'est que si on détruit une
industrie sucrière en interdisant la
production ici on se retrouve dans une
solide dans une situation totalement
absurde où l'europe ne pourra plus
produire son propre sucre et l'un
portera du brésil puisque les capacités
de production en europe elles peuvent
pas beaucoup monté à part en pologne et
que ça suffira pas on va importer du
sucre par exemple du brésil du sucre qui
est produit dans des conduites dans des
conditions qu'on n'oserait même pas
imaginer ici et ce sucre va traverser la
planète en bateau cette équation est
débile
débile mais personne n'a tiré le
raisonnement jusqu'au bout et en fait on
est souvent victime de ça quand on
traite des questions et recon c'est à
dire des idées qui sont lancés en l'air
et personnes qui n'ont envisage les
effets domino qui suivent et qui sont
souvent bien bien pires que le mal de la
même façon et j'en terminerai la barre
ça commence à être un peu long l'europe
est en train d'envisager une stratégie
agricole qui s'appelle farm tout fort et
dont les études sont en train de montrer
qu'elle qu'elle aboutit à deux résultats
3l sa boîte la production agricole qui
baissera de 25 % elle va faire augmenter
les prix pour les consommateurs de 12 à
15% et elle se traduit surtout par une
délégation au reste du monde des
inconvénients de l'agriculture c'est à
dire que les émissions de co2 seront
plus fait sur notre territoire elles
seront faites ailleurs et là je
m'interroge quel est le sens politique
de cette action là ça devrait tous nous
rendre fous et j'ai l'impression que
tout le monde s'en fiche
alors pour ceux qui nous écoutent est ce
que ce serait possible que vous
définissiez un petit peu
en quoi consistait ce positif quelles
sont les mesures qu'elle prévoit de
mettre en place et pourquoi est-ce que
ça amènerait ses conséquences alors
certes au fort c'est une vision c'est la
déclinaison agricole du green deal
européen c'est-à-dire unis des
commentaires très noble en est la base
faire en sorte que le continent européen
se remettre sur les rails un peu vert
diminue ses émissions de co2
drastiquement et prennent grand soin de
sa biodiversité
tout le monde est d'accord avec ça
simplement la façon dont l'europe
l'envisagent et de poupées part de deux
manières autoritaires les usages
d'intrants et de pesticides mais on n'a
pas de solution alternative c'est-à-dire
que si on prime l'agriculture d'engrais
et traitement des plantes on va faire
chuter pratiquement nos productions donc
ces productions là il va bien falloir
les remplacer vu que l'europe ne se
nourrit déjà pas tout seul
ensuite il ya un changement d'usagé des
terres
et puis une part accrue donnée à
l'agriculture biologique dont on sait
que les rendements sont bien un flingue
voilà en gros les grandes les grandes
lignes et donc tout ça ça signifie une
production de céréales qui va baisser de
web 1 30% quelque chose comme ça une
production de boeuf qui va baisser de
25% à vous allez me dire la viande un
bon pour le climat sauf que tout ça ça a
toujours des effets dominos derrière
c'est à dire une déprise agricole des
campagnes ça veut dire moins d'engrais
issus de l'élevage enfin ça veut dire
des prairies qui ne sont plus
entretenues et qui donc ne capte plus le
carbone qu'elle pourrait capter voilà
donc personne n'a modéliser sa en europe
avant de avant de proposer cette
orientation politique et ce sont
maintenant des idées des universités des
bureaux d'études économiques qui
modélise a posteriori les conséquences
de cette politique et qui tire la
sonnette d'alarmé en disant attention
attention on va dans le mur non
seulement on va saboter nos capacités
d'être en contrôle de notre alimentation
est donc de notre paix intérieure on va
se lancer sur les marchés mondiaux à la
course à notre subsistance alors que
cette concurrence va aller de plus en
plus brune et en plus écologiquement les
buts ne seront même pas atteint puisque
on va simplement déplacer les problèmes
voilà
vous avez parlé des arguments
écologiques ou pseudo écologique qu'ils
sont utilisés contre le glyphosate on a
aussi dans nos sociétés modernes les
arguments éthiques ou pseudo éthique qui
sont utilisés de plus en plus que ce
soit pour le glyphosate mais aussi pour
la question animale des conditions
d'élevage et il semble difficile de
concilier aujourd'hui l'élevage intensif
et le dernier train du mal on sait par
exemple qu environ 95% des porcs sont
élevés dans des bâtiments sur
caillebotis et enfermés ne voient pas la
lumière du jour comment répondez vous à
cette problématique la solution se
trouverait tel dans le développement de
la viande de synthèse cultivés dans des
laboratoires ou faut-il encourager et
aider nos agriculteurs à offrir de
meilleures conditions d'élevage aux
animaux
alors
c'est une question absolument capital et
qui préoccupe beaucoup de la société et
qui la préoccupe d'autant plus que la
société n'a plus à se battre pour se
nourrir ces questions là on se les pose
parce qu'on est aujourd'hui dans une
société à satiété c'est très bien c'est
très bien et effectivement
amélioré les conditions d'élevage c'est
capital c'est possible mais ça prend du
temps et ibf il faut comprendre
qu'effectivement on peut le faire mais
il faut laisser à la structure le temps
de s'adapter lui donner des objectifs
avant d'y arriver les avancées çà
existants par exemple depuis le 1er
janvier il ya deux choses très
importantes qui sont passés dans
l'agriculture en france la première
c'est
le fait qu'on ne détruit plus enfin
qu'on ne tue plus les poussins mâles
pour la production d avec eux ce sont
donc les p'tites poules femelle qui
pondent des oeufs et que donc les races
de poules qu'on fait éclore pour pondre
des oeufs produisent des mâles et des
femelles et on n'a pas besoin des petits
mâles qui sont pas on peut pas aller
consommer comme des poulets de chair pas
les mêmes vagues les mêmes rast poulet
et donc ont tué ces petits poussins à
petit il devenait la nourriture pour
animaux donc c'est éthiquement
effectivement difficilement défendable
voire pas du tout défendable de faire
naître des êtres vivants pour les tuer
aussi daumas qui ne correspond pas une
nécessité de production tout le monde
est d'accord là dessus et on a donc le
dis depuis
quatre ans en france qu'on allait en
terminer avec cette pratique et il a
fallu quatre ans à toute la filière
volaille pour trouver une solution pour
éliminer les eaux avant que naissent les
poussins on a dû mettre au point des
machines sophistiquées qui détecte le
sexe des poussins dans les eaux de
manière à détruire d oeil non pas des
êtres vivants donc ça on peut quand même
considérer que c'est un progrès
simplement c'est un coûter cher et ça a
pris du temps il faut comprendre que
c'est possible mais comme ça une
conséquence pour les consommateurs un
petit renchérissement de la nourriture
lors ces mini mains sur les yeux mais
bon ça existe que ça déstabilise aussi
les déséquilibres économiques des
exploitations pour qu'elles fassent la
transition
il peut voilà c'est une nouvelle manière
le faire il faudrait il faut réorganiser
voilà ça prend du temps de la même
manière on a décidé depuis le 1er
janvier c'est pareil un travail long que
la castration à vif des porcelets qui
était indéfendable et c'est vrai c'est
une souffrance animale qui n'est pas
défendable mais il a fallu trouver des
solutions pour soi ne plus castrés les
porcs mais ça pose des gros problèmes
parce que la viande de porc parfois les
pentes sont à castres et elle est pas
consommables et elle a une odeur qui est
désagréable et on peut pas vous pas la
manger et puis ou alors trouver des
solutions alternatives pour faire en
sorte que
les porcelets soit castrés avec une
anesthésie
et puis je reviens sur un petit peu en
arrière mais castrés les portes ça ça
c'est aussi parfois une nécessité pour
faire la charcuterie parce que les porcs
castrés sont plus gras et donc si vous
voulez du moment de bayonne par exemple
vous pouvez pas faire sans donc il y
avait une vraie question d'organisation
de la production et petit à petit va
toute la filière porc s'est mise en
nombre pour soi cesser la castration
dans ses pouces il soit la faire dans
des conditions sans souffrance pour les
animaux voilà c'est pareil ça prend du
temps alors la question de l'élevage
intensif c'est une vraie bonne question
et on est confronté à nos propres
paradoxe parce que par exemple quand on
parle du poulet on sait que la france
produit à peu près
25% des poulets qu'elle consomme hors
domicile c'est à dire dans les
sandwiches dans les restaurants etc le
reste des poulets est importé
essentiellement d'ukraine de pologne
voire du brésil est produit dans des
conditions qui sont encore pire que ce
qu'on peut avoir dans les très heureuse
élevage de volailles donc la solution ce
serait de réimplanter des élevages avec
des normes qui nous convienne mieux mais
on ne peut pas implanter des élevages en
france parce que les riverains n'en
veulent pas donc on est toujours
confronté à des problématiques qui sont
insolubles à des commentaires à des
doubles standards intellectuelle de
notre part à tous sont pas consommateurs
et effectivement
le port sur caillebotis
ça fait débat c'est compliqué mais quand
on s'intéresse à ce sujet on se rend
compte qu'il ya aussi des raisons
sanitaires poussins et que idéalement
effectivement on pense tous que les
portes devraient être élevées en plein
air mais ça implique de telles surfaces
d'élevage pour satisfaire notre
consommation que ça paraît presque
impossible
alors effectivement
la consommation
de viande est à questionner notre régime
alimentaire pas pour l'éliminer du tout
moi je ne suis pas du tout dans cette
optique là il faut sans doute qu'on se
pose la question du moins et du mieux et
du moins et du plus rémunérateurs pour
nos éleveurs et des meilleures
conditions pour les animaux alors tout
ça ce sont des équations qui sont
extrêmement complexes qui nécessitent
comme je le disais tout à l'heure qu'on
tire bien chaque fil de nos exigences
jusqu'au bout pour être bien sûr que ça
n'a pas des résultats qui sont pires
c'est à dire qu'il aboutirait par
exemple a plus de production ici mais
importer une production vraiment bien
moins dix ans est bien moins bonne en
termes de bien-être animal pour
remplacer ce qu'on ne ferait plus la
voyez si on il faut bien tiré les fils
avant de prendre des décisions pour
améliorer globalement le système
d'élevage d'une manière générale il ya
déjà des types d'élevage qui pose plus
de questions ou d'autres par exemple la
volaille le port effectivement il faut
se poser des questions il ya d'autres
types des vaches sur un point très peu
l'élevage des moutons par exemple en
france se fait quasiment en plein air
toute l'année 90% du temps l'élevage des
bovins en france est victime de beaucoup
de fausses d'idées les vaches sont
globalement élevé à l'herbe ou avec des
productions de la ferme en france à 80%
et on dit qu'elles sont gavés au soja ça
représente une toute petite partie de
leur alimentation c'est un ou deux
pourcent cette alimentation la hausse
au-delà du soja importé effectivement
fait pas une très bonne idée et il faut
se poser la question de savoir comment
on peut la remplacer par des production
de protéines végétales ici en france
mais ça veut dire qu'à chaque fois
chaque fois il faut retirer les fils de
nos exigences alimentaires jusqu'au bout
alors qui dit mieux produire vous
l'avais dit il ya aussi peut-être moins
de quantité et pourtant on se retrouve
face à des défis mondiaux puisque selon
les dernières projections de l'onil nous
serons à 9,7 milliards d'habitants en
2050 et 11 milliards la sonde e siècle
et les rapports du giec alarme aussi sur
la question de la nutrition et de
l'accès pour tous à l'alimentation
comment pensez vous alors l'avenir du
modèle agricole français et européens
alors même que les agriculteurs souvent
anglais qui font face aux aléas
climatiques et doivent répondre aux
injonctions des citoyens en leur
demandant de sortir de l'agriculture
dite productiviste oui alors ça c'est
une vraie fiction et c'est encore une
question qui est observé par nous par
des gens qui n'ont jamais manqué qui
n'ont jamais été en situation de disette
et qui ne savent pas en fait ce que
c'est qu'une
société ou une économie en pension
alimentaire il ya des pays qui sont en
train de découvrir ce que c'est de
manière assez dramatique par exemple le
liban qui est un pays où on est en ce
moment un pays de pénurie grave parce
que c'est un fait qui est déstabilisée
par ailleurs beaucoup d'autres questions
politiques et ça fait une société
complètement déstructuré et une société
qui ne sait pas comment elle longera le
soir c'est une société complètement
déstructurée c'est le lot d'une bonne
partie de la planète
après la pandémie mondiale l'onu le
programme alimentaire mondial estime qu
environ un milliard de dhs et humain de
cette planète sont en situation de fin
que des centaines de millions d'autres
sont dans des situations de
nourriture insuffisante de comment dire
de disette ou de dénutrition et la
population mondiale croît
alors on doit quand même bien se rendre
compte quand on parle de tout ça que
l'agriculture dite productiviste a
abouti quand même auto de famine le plus
bas que l'humanité ait jamais connu en
dépit du fait que la population n'ait
jamais été aussi nombreuses
il ya trois ans de ça avant la pandémie
la fin n'avait jamais été aussi basses
dans ce qu'il veut quand même dire que
il ya certaines vertus à ce système
évidemment ces minutes qu'il touche
assez vite en terme de diversité ou de
pollution mais il ya quand même décider
comment dire des choses à nuancer et à
mesurer alors pour ce qui est de
l'europe il ya c'est une équation à
double tranchant l'europe qui se
priverait des capacités de sa
subsistance et qui refuseraient
désormais de de collaborer aux grands
équilibres alimentaires mondiaux
auraient une terrible responsabilité
alors on entend souvent on n'a qu'à
développer les agricultures locales et
les agricultures paysannes c'est parce
que l'europe avec ses produits exportés
à saboter les agricultures locales alors
ça a été vrai parfois c'est globalement
très faux il faut quand même se rend
compte que par exemple sur les céréales
le blé on le produit sur certaines aires
géographiques de la planète est en
dessous de certaines latitudes c'est
tout simplement pas possible donc les
céréales étant la base de l'alimentation
mondiale on ne fera pas l'économie de se
demander comment les bassins producteurs
peuvent contribuer aux agriculteurs aux
agriculteurs aux équilibres alimentaires
des zones géographiques qui le
produisent pas de céréales ça ça relève
simplement d'une 16 espèces d'égoïsme
occidentale et c'est vraiment très
compliqué c'est difficilement tenable
donc encore une fois il faut voir la
grande image l'autre conséquence d'une
europe qui refuseraient de jouer ce jeu
là et qui par exemple compterait sur les
importations pour un sûr et sain de
subsistance tout en exigeant des
produits avec les standards de qualité
meilleure ou en exigeant par exemple du
bio je peux je place pas forcément dans
les comptes dans l'est dans les
standards de qualité meilleure c'est une
autre façon de produits c'est une façon
de déstructurer un peu plus les
économies qu'ils produiront cette
alimentation pour nous parce que si on
exige d'importer du bio venus d'amérique
du sud c'est de la nourriture qui sera
inaccessible pour les populations
locales qui en plus se fera de la
déforestation pour notre bien-être à
nous et pour moi ça me semble
extrêmement questionnable et ce serait
une responsabilité énorme des pays
développés que de se servir un peu plus
des ressources de la planète alors que
justement il refuse de collaborer et que
justement les besoins sont croissants
absolument partout
donc voilà il ya des vraies questions à
poser sur la table
alors souvent on repose la question de
l'élevage en expliquant que les
c'est de la ressource alimentaire peut
être utilisé par les animaux ou pas par
les humains je crois qu'il faut vraiment
vraiment nuancer cette si cette idée là
il ya une question à se poser sur les
images mais la plupart du temps ce que
mangent les amis nous ce ne sont pas des
choses que pourrait manger les humains
par exemplaire de la prairie je connais
pas du moins qu'il qui la consomment et
c'est aussi une manière de bien
concentré l'énergie de manière efficace
donc avant le cheveu de se lancer dans
bay dans des raisonnements actif sûr on
a karaté l'élevage et mangé tous des
protéagineux il faut vraiment se poser
la question de la pertinence de ce
raisonnement qu'il ne tient que sur des
hypothèses et des mentions du scratch
on l'entend très régulièrement même
constamment
le la question climatique et
l'agriculture est souvent est souvent
amenée à être répondu avec l'argument
locale la consommation locale et on voit
émerger de nouveaux types de
consommateurs que l'on appelle les
locavores qui se revendique donc une
consommation uniquement et simplement
locale pensez vous que ça puisse être
étendue à l'échelle nationale et que ce
soit viable comme mode de consommation
alors c'est une chose très intéressante
le circuit court vous pourrez appeler le
circuit coup mais je vais profiter de ce
moment pour dire il n'y a pas de
solution unique il faut se faire à
l'idée que la question agricole et
l'agression alimentaire c'est une
question complexe qui va demander qu'on
mette en oeuvre des quantités de choses
différentes et des quantités d'échelle
d'évaluation différentes une fois que
j'ai dit ça oui je crois que relocaliser
notre agriculture ça a vraiment un sens
à plusieurs à plusieurs échelles d'une
part parce que
ça n'a pas de sens de faire traverser à
la planète de la nourriture quand on
peut la produire à côté de chez soi et
je crois par exemple il va falloir qu'on
se repose la question de comment est-ce
qu'on alimente nos quand ils en france
en europe ça ne paraît pas très logique
quand on a une zone de production comme
la france qu'on importe de la nourriture
d'ailleurs pour alimenter les cantines
donc il faut vraiment se poser la
question de comment êtes vous plaidez
les cantines à acheter des choses plus
local ça une autre vertu le fait que les
citoyens puissent avoir des liens avec
les gens qui produisent la nourriture ça
donne beaucoup d'idées reçues deux
jugements à l'emporte-pièce sur
l'agriculture de on nous empoisonne on
nous ment et c'est
souvent discuté avec les gens qui
produit c'est aussi se rendre compte des
contraintes de la réalité des saisons de
la réalité des ravageurs des cultures
changer bien des choses aussi simples
que ça que m pardon les citoyens
français
massivement urbanisées avec une pyramide
démographique agricole qui s'est
rétrécie donc beaucoup moins de gens qui
font de la pédagogie agricole finalement
les citoyens ont perdu 7 septembre sont
là donc c'est aussi une façon de faire
vivre économiquement les territoires en
assurant des revenus corrects aux
agriculteurs en supprimant une partie de
la chaîne des changes et en laissant la
valeur là où elle est donc ça ça me
paraît vraiment le bon sens le plus
absolu et ça me paraît vraiment crucial
pour qu'on réfléchisse aux aberrations
qu'on a à transporter un animal sur des
centaines de kilomètres pour le ramener
une fois mort pour le transformer va
vous dire il ya effectivement des choses
totalement débile dans notre système
alimentaire on a aussi détruit des pans
de nos de notre agriculture qu'on est
désormais obligée d'importer par exemple
quand vous voulez des fraises pour faire
les frais du gaou on importe souvent les
fesses de chine parce qu'on a détruit la
finalité est tout simplement plus la
ressource donc il faut se poser la
question de relocaliser là aussi une
partie nos productions agricoles
notamment les fruits et légumes parce
que ça n'a aucun sens de le faire
ailleurs alors qu'on pourrait le faire
ici
mais l'agriculture sa voix ça doit se
penser à plusieurs niveaux il ya ce
niveau local il ya un niveau
intermédiaire à l'échelle de la france
est-ce que c'est logique qu'il ya des
bassins de production par exemple on
fait pas beaucoup de céréales dans le
sud de la france c'est pas une raison
pour laquelle on doit pas manger du pain
dans le sort dans le sud de la france
ont produit beaucoup de fruits dans la
vallée du rhône c'est pas une raison
pour laquelle on devrait pas manger des
pêches dans le nord-pas-de-calais qui
n'ont produit pas la france n'est pas un
très grand pays en termes de superficie
c'est quand même bien doit aussi quand
même se concevoir comme une zone de
production et c'est normal que les
échanges à l'intérieur et puis comme je
le disais tout à l'heure il ya aussi la
question de l'international de la
stabilisation des bassins de population
et le fait que la france avec ses
céréales qui exporte la moitié est un
produit film génial les exports par
exemple vers l'égypte vers le maroc
c'est une façon de stabiliser des pays
en leur évitant les émeutes de la faim
et ça il faut bien comprendre ça c'était
aussi une responsabilité politique
d'exporter de la nourriture pour
stabiliser
pays alors c'est hélas elle est
controversée on mise donc un seul se
débrouiller on n'a qu'à les laisser se
construire une agriculture
moi j'ai pas vu beaucoup de céréales
poussé en egypte et en tout cas pas
suffisamment pour nourrir une population
qui est en constante augmentation et qui
est très jeune voilà donc il faut
vraiment se poser la question de de
notre production et de notre système
alimentaire avec plusieurs niveaux de
lecture l'un excluant jamais l'autre
alors on al impression qu on a des gros
problèmes de de communication et de
céder des grands enjeux auxquels font
face les agriculteurs aujourd'hui on a
parlé de beaucoup de problèmes on parle
de revenus etc mais il ya aussi un
problème de reconnaissance et de
conditions de vie on est face à un mal
être général de nos agriculteurs en
france et vous l'avez souligné dans
cette entrevue et dans le dernier
article s'ils sont alarmants les
agriculteurs ont selon les âges et 43 %
à 200 % plus de risques que les autres
français de se suicider quels sont selon
vous les principales causes de ce mal
être et quelles solutions peut-on
trouver pour iv pour
alors il ya plusieurs choses d'une part
quand vous êtes une population qui
démographiquement décroît ça veut dire
que tout le système social autour de
vous s'effrite les agriculteurs étaient
très nombreux dans les campagnes dans
les villages et donc sa forme est une
forme de société cohérent et donc il y
avait une compréhension générale de la
manière dont on vivait au rythme des
saisons avec quelles contraintes etc ou
peut-être une forme d'entre elles aussi
et puis il y avait aussi une
compréhension politique de ce qu est l
agriculture pense que dans les conseils
municipaux il ya encore trente ans il y
avait beaucoup d'agriculteurs mais comme
ils sont à 25 % de la population
désormais ils n'ont plus leur place dans
ces instances dans ces instances
politiques locales ça veut dire aussi
que la collectivité ne comprend plus
forcément leurs problématiques leur
manière de travailler
et puis la ville a gagné dans beaucoup
d'endroits en prêt en l'emprise c'est à
dire qu on a construit des lotissements
au bord des champs etc et l'agriculture
qui vivait sa vie s'est retrouvé
confronté à des gens qui avaient un
rythme de vie différent des
préoccupations différentes et qui vivait
assez mal
la vie agricole à côté de chez eux ça
fait du bruit ça fait de la poussière
des épandages de pesticides ça sent
mauvais parfois quand on met du deal etc
et on s'est retrouvé avec des groupes
lilloise images qui se sont souvent
ambleny mais avec des mondes qui ne se
comprenaient plus qu'ils ne se
comprenaient pas et puis politiquement
la grille trouve est assez mal
représentés il ya beaucoup de députés
agriculteurs enfin voila c'est devenu un
monde qui c'est qui s'est coupé du reste
de la société pour d'autres raisons
aussi
la plupart des familles ont des ancêtres
agriculteurs et jusqu'il ya encore
trente ou quarante ans les enfants aller
en vacances dans la famille dans la
ferme et ses banques avaient un vernis
de connaissance une idée de ce que
c'était que cette ville à ce lien là il
s'est coupé et puis ces coupes et aussi
parce que les gens achètent leur
nourriture au supermarché qu'elle est
souvent transformé les cubains
effectivement on sait plus on sait plus
comment ça se compose un plat avec de la
farine qui vient de là des fruits qui
viennent de là et c'est enfin on sait
plus et donc les agriculteurs se sont se
sont retrouvés dans cette situation là
où on a perdu l'idée de la
reconnaissance on avait eu pour eux dans
les années soixante soixante dix quand
ils ont commencé à nous mêmes en france
et où on n'a plus vu socialement que les
nuisances de l'agriculture et on ne
traite l'agriculture calque à la lecture
est qu'à la lumière de ces nuisances
plus jamais sous l'angle du bénéfice
économique il y a à maîtriser son destin
en main et ça fait des agriculteurs qui
ont l'impression qu'on leur manque de
respect qu'on leur manque de
reconnaissance et puis ce phénomène qui
s'est développée d'agly bashing expliqué
que l'agriculture connu que
l'agriculture c'est mal que
l'agriculture c'est la mort des abeilles
etc avec souvent des beaucoup de
mauvaise foi et beaucoup de
manipulations et beaucoup de
parole à l'emporte-pièce sans jamais
aucune nuance ça fait un monde qui va
pas très bien qui voit en plus sa
population vieillir qui sent qu'il a du
mal à attirer des jeunes générations et
à transmettre qu'il a
qui évolue beaucoup qui a
considérablement changé ses méthodes de
travail reste que quand on voit par
exemple les usages de pesticides ils ont
considérablement baissé au cours des 20
dernières années personne ne prend le
point de se retourner et de regarder les
chiffres ce qu'ils étaient il ya vingt
ans mais les progrès ont été réalisés
d'une manière extraordinaire
les fermes ont considérablement changé
dans leur manière d'être gérés dans leur
production elle innove beaucoup la
plupart des agriculteurs sont
extrêmement bien formés désormais quand
on regarde le niveau de formation des
agriculteurs n'est souvent très très
surpris de leur niveau global de
connaissance de leur niveau global de
diplômes et tout ça n'est pas reconnu
par la population qui tout simplement ne
parle plus à son agriculture
la france est un grand pays rural qui a
un peu honte de lui-même qui a un peu
oublié ses racines qui a oublié d'où il
vient et donc je pense qu'effectivement
il ya une urgence 1 re parler
d'agriculture comme d'un phénomène
social et écologique et pas simplement
comme un phénomène de santé publique le
oud comme un problème d'environnement
l'agriculture n'est pas un problème
d'environnement l'agriculture a un
aspect environnemental est crucial à
saisir et à améliorer ça n'est pas
exactement la même chose
alors pour terminer et pour résumer un
peu tous ces points qu'on a abordé sur
la question agricole française que
pensez vous et que penser généralement
de l'initiative du gouvernement les
états généraux de l'alimentation qui
peuvent être vues clairement comme une
tentative de mesures politiques pour
adresser l'ensemble de ces problèmes
alors la démarche initiale était
vraiment une très bonne idée c'est à
dire
ça ça résume un peu tout ce que je j'ai
dit avant on a pris conscience qu'on
n'avait plus vraiment comment dire de
connaissances ou d'image fiable de ce
qu'était notre système agricole et
alimentaire et on s'est dit on va mettre
autour de la table tous les maillons de
cette chaîne de production c'est-à-dire
les agriculteurs c'est à dire même
l'amont agricole les fournisseurs
d'intrants de terreur de matériel on va
mettre autour de la table la chaîne
intermédiaires c'est à dire la première
transformation la deuxième
transformation agroalimentaire on va
mettre aussi autour de la table la
grande distribution puisque c'est
aujourd'hui le canal par lequel on
achète 75 ou 80 cents notre nourriture
en france et puis on va aussi mettre les
consommateurs et on va se rendre compte
que toute cette chaîne est malade et
attentes qui sont pas les mêmes nous
tout simplement et qui sont qui sont ou
qui sont difficiles à concilier les
agriculteurs veulent vivre correctement
les pme de la grippe de
l'agroalimentaire aussi les grandes
entreprises de l'agroalimentaire mais
pas exactement les mêmes soucis parce
qu'elles sont elles des marges
importantes
la grande distribution a sa propre
problématique de marge et les
consommateurs ont des problèmes de
budget et veulent payer moins cher leur
alimentation on se rend bien compte à un
moment que la valeur dans cette chaîne
dont cette chaîne alimentaire elle est
très très très disputé mais ça c'est la
vraie question alors il ya toute la
question de remettre de la valeur dans
notre agriculture ça ça ne peut se
concevoir que si les citoyens ont
conscience des efforts qui sont faits en
amont en termes de meilleures pratiques
environnementales et pense que ça c'est
réel en termes de meilleures pratiques
de bien-être animal parce que c'est long
mais que effectivement ça avance et on
le sait pas assez et que tout ceci a un
coût et donc il ya toute cette question
de comment est ce qu'on essaye de mettre
de la fluidité dans notre système
alimentaire pour que ce soit plus juste
pour tous du producteur au consommateur
on se rend compte après c'est plus ça
fait quatre ans cinq peut-être que c'est
extrêmement difficile
que les acteurs sont capables de
s'entendre dans une s'entendre au sens
par entente illicite du terme mais par
exemple on a vu dans la crise sanitaire
que toute notre chaîne alimentaire a
fait bloc qu'elle s'est extrêmement bien
comportée que les acteurs ont été
solidaires les uns des autres est
relativement bien compris les
problématiques des uns et des autres et
que le finalement les consommateurs ne
manquer de rien je rappelle de ses
besoins pressants les consommateurs
français n'ont manqué de rien dans la
pandémie alors que l'économie était à
l'arrêt je sais pas si on se rend bien
compte de la chance qu'on a eu ça aurait
pu être un drame on est passé à côté
parce qu'on a eu un système qui est
extrêmement solide et ça ça ça ça
questionne vendredi notre système est à
bout de souffle moi je ne crois pas
qu'il soit poudre mais on se rend quand
même content que la maintenant que la
situation est devenue à bompas normal
mais quasi normal c'est reparti on a des
gars des prix on a une grande
distribution qui ne veut pas passer les
hausses de coûts des matières premières
alors que toute la chaîne de production
a vu ses coûts explosent et pour les
intrants pour l'énergie les cours des
céréales qui explose partout dans le
monde donc on se rend compte que cette
ces états généraux de l'alimentation
était prometteur et que malheureusement
on n'a encore pas trouvé la solution
alors on rectifie la loi régulièrement
parce que les négociations se passent
pas bien etc on a aussi un système en
france qui fonctionne sur des
négociations commerciales ce qui est
quand même une espèce d'exception
mondial 7-6 négociations entre la grande
distribution et ses fournisseurs qui
sont quand même source de tension qui
permette fawara kick ass et un cadre
très contraint par lequel passent souple
et qui fonctionne pas très bien et qu'on
n'a pas remis en question donc voilà les
états généraux l'alimentation sera quand
même permis de faire un panorama de se
rendre compte où étaient nos ressources
le ce rende compte d'un certain nombre
de problèmes et de manque de faire des
constats beaucoup de constats et
finalement
de résoudre quelques problèmes mais
vraiment pas tout simplement ce que ce
voile à ce travail là il va devoir
continuer peut-être changer de forme en
tout cas il n'est pas arrivée pas abouti
autant qu'il le devrait on va terminer
sur cette belle ouverture qui donne voir
au prochain président ou à la prochaine
plaisante pour le prochain mandat en
espérant qu'ils puissent continuer sur
cette lancée et les autres d'autres
problèmes je vous remercie mais du coup
pour cette belle entrevue et pour votre
temps et de merci à vous et je remercie
les personnes qui nous devons écouter
n'hésitez pas à suivre les articles les
parutions et sert à l'âme et du croquis
sont toujours intéressantes et
pertinentes et parfois à contre-courant
de ce qu'on peut voir le plus sûr sont
des réseaux sociaux et je vous ai vite
évident je vous invite évidemment à
suivre scopeo sur youtube et sur les
réseaux sociaux pour être au courant de
secours continuent à publier merci
beaucoup merci
merci à tous cette journée